dérivé du médicament princeps le
générique pourtant 20 à 60% moins cher
que le produit d'origine ne séduit pas
encore tous les français pharmaciens et
médecins s'unissent à lever les derniers
freins à la prise de ces médicaments
le patient se rend compte que certains
médicaments agissent autrement
je prends l'exemple du paracétamol en
fonction du de la manière dont il est
administré en comprimés ou gélules
en tout ce qu'on voudra et bâle la
vitesse à laquelle le médicament agit et
la durée d'action varient d'une personne
à une autre
convaincre son patient de prendre à
génériques lui apporter des informations
précises c'est le défi quotidien des
professionnels de santé et de la
campagne de promotion il faut que le
pharmacien le médecin soit déjà
convaincus eux mêmes que les produits
sont similaires à 99% d'entre eux au
médicament qui a fait ses preuves
pendant dix ans qui est le médicament
princeps pour les aider une campagne
publicitaire vient consolider la
confiance et la connaissance de ces
médicaments
un moyen compréhensible qui lève le
doute sur ses jeunes
ils permettent de d'une façon
compréhensible par tout le monde 2 2
de comprendre que c'est un enjeu pour
pour l'ensemble des patients et qu'il ya
une réelle sécurité de ces produits là
voilà et qu'on peut traiter toutes les
maladies les plus bénigne au plus grave
avec les médicaments génériques
c'est ça qui est important à l'avenir la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
prévoit comme objectif une prise de
médicaments génériques dont 86% des cas